перш за все Я хотів би висловити подяку
чесному поліцейському який не дав
можливості затулити цю справу по-друге
по-друге Я хотів би наголосити парламент
зараз зробив помилку треба припинити
займатися піарами поважати вищі
законодавчий орган держави одну з гілок
влади тому що вирок був винесений вчора
через 10 днів він вступить в законну
силу і Відповідно до Конституції
трухим буде позбавлений мандатої - Це не
потребує нашого голосування замість
цього ми дали людині яка отримала
кримінальний вирок з почесності залишити
Верховну Раду я твердо переконаний що
зараз Верховна Рада зробила помилку
треба було відповідно до вироку Він має
позбавлений мандату і піти геть Дякую за
увагу і слава Україні